you are a single eligible bachelor what
would it take for you to date during
kovat today right now man you would have
to have like test results I'm really
good at picking out who's been like
really wild and who's like actually been
quarantined because I'm like I was in
you know I was here when it was a hot
spot when New York was a hot spot I'm a
ninja with the quarantine I'm cold
bloody with it man like I gods wrong so
I can actually and and and how you ask
you don't act straight out because
people will lie you just get them real
comfortable you just ask so like man
that's crazy so this quarantine thing
giant crazy I would just love to kick it
with like I collect some people and a
little party you know me so like on the
load sick and then they'll be still say
something this happened she's like yeah
you should have been with us last week a
moon to this cabin but don't tell
anybody I'm like how well and I'll see
you in 2021 you reckless mother so it's
your own it's your own sting operation
yes what sounds like you're in a lonely
period right now but that's yeah very
lonely I watched a watch porn so much I
think I've seen all of it and I've
started sitting script notes yeah you're
starting to so brilliant first of all
that's something to say you've watched
all the porn not that I was to me yes
it's like it's like is it h DS at 4k HD
we don't we don't actually need it to be
that clear I don't want to see and hear
someone crying
I don't need that you know I'm glad that
we started this conversation with you
raping so much money for kovat 19
protests relief fund and then as always
with me we end up talking about
pornography and how it could be better
[Laughter]
well I am I'm thrilled you're doing such
amazing stuff I mean as an artist but
also getting involved and and and doing
what you're doing
I really do salute you I just
get the message out you can support the
co vid 19 protest relief fund by going
to kovat 19 protest relief dot-com